[Musique]
c'est là dans la pose de la pierre ça me
dérange pas mais taper famille tu sais
c'était à la place tu comparais que j'ai
pas le choix
[Musique]
gagner le premier twilight user ta tête
tu as peut-être la tête et c'est quoi
c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi là on va où là toi tu vas tu
cherches une planche à découper en avant
a convié ses pierres neuf ans déjà
t'imagines ça file et toi alors mais moi
je sais toi ça va mon coeur n'y pense
même pas géniale est de chacun allez
maintenant quand tu fonces moss est
toujours au patron du l'heure qu'il est
mais toute attente puis 45 minutes je
sais pas si je serai ses bonnes pour
tenir son rôle pierre commence déjà par
ne plus parler toi ô féminin est
d'accord c'est fatigant nettoie tous ça
c'est que ce qui s'est passé j'ai eu mes
règles
j'ai eu la peur de ma vie mais ce que
vous ne m'entendez mademoiselle je ne
gagerais mademoiselle monde à part de
madame madame si madame madame pénélope
eric oui oui mon chéri bisous bisous
tu appelles rythme on chérit bête
appelle bien perdre ma chérie à droite
ainsi qu'olivier ça va pas si si si si
ça va c'est très bien le bureau pense
qu'à essayer par là oui oui
perso
ma voiture sans suite du gardiste suffit
maintenant je gagne à excuser alors tu
viens de me briser des ovaires on chie
le constat thurmond data savonnette